so like favors men really so it's how
it's a bit unfair to just say how does
Okay can I can I have an example how how
does society favor men well like the
high paying jobs I know you're gonna say
women don't want to do the the high
paying jobs but most of the high paying
jobs they favor men like a woman has to
work most ten times let me ask you a few
questions those roles let me let me ask
you a question
um the NBA it's it's mostly it's mostly
it's like what 60 70 black roughly do
they discriminate against Asians there's
like no Asians in the NBA
oh so you're saying they're better no no
no no no I'm saying does the NBA
discriminate against Asians there are
very few Asians in the NBA what I'm
saying is in any group you you're never
going to find true equality when of
outcome because different groups like
different things so I think Asians make
up like 90 something percent of like I
don't there's they're like typically in
the U.S sorry please don't come at me
for stereotypes but but but they make up
a higher percentage of like like higher
education admission yeah so you're never
going to have true equality and it's
like me personally so but I'm saying
that I'm saying we shouldn't I don't
care about men
no I'm saying we shouldn't fight for
True equality because people want to do
different things in different groups and
I'm saying in the top one percent I've
seen what it takes to get there I've
seen firsthand I've seen my dad like
grow up he he worked 60 70 hours a week
he didn't have a life he didn't have
friends most women Valley like we value
a social life we value having fun like
what I've had to do the last three years
to build this like Jess most most girls
would not do it oh no not at all oh no
and it's like it's like and that's okay
but that doesn't mean women are being
discriminated against it means they
don't want to work 60 70 hours a week I
interviewed top like
um I decided I wanted more rich friends
when I lived in Milwaukee and I just
asked Executives if I could like a
billion dollar companies if I could sit
there have a coffee with them and just
interview them about their life and both
of them are that I got to interview I
could see the one deficit they had in
their life neither of them really had
families and it was really sad and you
can tell both of them like missed out on
a part of life and you could tell they
regretted it you can't have everything
and women don't want to do those roles
because they are
ungodly hard can you imagine having like
some women do you're you're but it's a
lot harder I said I said I think like in
the 90s women couldn't even vote this is
in the 90s in the 90s so yeah it was
like 1918 yeah no that's not women got
the right to vote 20s no it was 1918.
you said 18 18 oh 18.
okay
so remember but why why didn't women
have the right to vote women so
historically men had to go to war and
fight that is why women couldn't vote
was because we if you had the choice
today in 2022 when we were in war and
you had to go fight on the front lines
would you pick it I personally and this
is where people take me out of context
and say I don't think women should vote
personally if I in 2022 had the choice
where I had to go fight in the front
lines just like the men in a war or I
could give up my right to vote I would
give up my right to vote and that's what
happened back then is they equated
voting with going into war because all
I'm trying to put it I agree with that
because yeah men do take a lot on
themselves the fact that they fight for
us I I appreciate that but the stuff
that they do but I couldn't but I'm
saying I'm saying we weren't
discriminated against it was just how
Society ran we weren't discriminated
against we had a freedom like that was a
freedom that came with the
responsibility of getting drafted that
wasn't discrimination if you wanted to
be equally drafted go vote yeah but what
I'm trying to say is that's how who's
picking that who's anyone anyone yeah
like I would give it up that's what a
point yeah because they talked about
politics and it's also the same thing
women didn't have access to education
they couldn't own property which means
that realistically it was you you could
typically remember back then it was
typical for people to get married young
so it was typical for them so so the the
reason was when you were married it was
you were looked at as one and that was
and typically women submitted to their
husbands and trusted their husbands with
their judgment women like tip so that's
why the property like the property thing
happened and same with the property it
was like like women still could own
properties if they did not get married
um but you know but typically then women
got married
if we want to go back into history I'll
tell you something about history that I
think and this is why shout out Emily I
mentioned that's why I mentioned to
um Andrew Tate that my problem wasn't
necessary with Ben it is with the men
that are running the machine that
obviously controls our societies because
when women first started going to work
they started going to work out of the
fact that there was a lack of men in the
country because there was war going on
war wars so women had to pick up go to
work and do their thing cool from the
aftermath of War there as women that
already in the workplace and then
there's women that also left widowed
which means that they now have a choice
either you stop at home with your family
become and stay a housewife or you're
gonna get up and you're gonna go to work
and that's how a lot of women have
become what they call masculine because
they come out of a trauma they come out
also the consequences of history and
this is why at this point and what I've
been trying to say for time is let's
stop trying to blame women for what's
going on in society right now let's
understand that this is a construct and
a consequence of history and last let's
start respecting because we cannot go
back and and I I agree with you I'm not
I'm not saying it's one gender or the
other I'm just saying like we have been
talking about the man forever
it's like we like they I don't want no
scrubs scrubs
like there's there's no there's no
there's no song saying I don't want no
whale a whale like nobody's saying that
and I'm saying like we they have had
like we have had decades where we
started it's like now the men are
finally talking and we can't even give
them their Fair that's kind of true
because even men when they're singing
about women they sang a lot about love
songs it was nice
I feel like from the moment you're born
I don't know if it's just in an African
home in an African home you're literally
race to cater for your man from uh
I was eight so you're like you need to
know how you work for your mouth you
need to know you should for your man you
should be thankful you were naturally
taught game a lot of girls didn't get
taught that they didn't get that yeah
like a lot of a lot of women would love
like eat I mean my parents just started
my parents my parents started dating
when they were 17. my mom taught me no
game she's like meet your husband in
high school a lot of women aren't taught
the basic necessities of being a woman
like cooking shocking to me yeah so it's
a privilege like you you have something
in your holster in your bag that you can
whip out whenever you need to for a man
like okay I can cook for him I can clean
for him because you have it on you a lot
of women had to learn that on their on
their own or just had to go throughout
life and learning it they they never
taught it or they never needed to have
it until they were in a position where
like oh I I can't do this on my own I
can't cook I can't clean I can't work a
simple vacuum I can't do this because
things have been done for me my whole
life or I was never taught that and so
you shouldn't look at it as it like oh I
was taught this from jump I was taught
how to cater to my man or be a woman you
should take them and like African women
or like women like me Nigerian
background especially that's all we know
it's about even like now I'm 26 my mom
tells me if I'm 30 without a husband I'm
basically used okay okay but you you at
least so so if you look at dating app
data as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible